so it's fun to be here I want to talk to
you about social science this morning
and in particular this field that I've
been involved with for several years now
which we call computational social
science so just to give you a sense of
you know many of you probably feel like
most people are a little unclear like
what social science actually is and what
makes it social so you know my sort of
personal view on this is that the kinds
of phenomenon that social scientists
study whether you're sociologists or an
economist or a political scientist all
intrinsically involve large numbers of
people interacting with each other
alright so if we think about
organizations or firms or political
parties or markets or cultures these are
the objects the actors that that social
scientists are interested in but we also
realize that at some level these are all
just convenient fictions that we're
talking about that at the root level
that's actually just people and these
people are interacting with each other
in complicated ways over time and it and
they're producing this kind of emergent
level phenomenon that we're studying and
so in in in sociology we call this the
micro macro problem how do you get from
the level of individual people to this
macro level of social facts and
phenomena and so the sort of central
challenge that we face as social
scientists is that is that these
problems are just intrinsically
difficult to study so why are they
difficult if you're if you're talking
about you know hundreds or thousands or
millions of people interacting with each
other just trying to observe those
interactions over time is already an
extraordinary empirical exercise it's
something that you know for most of the
history of social science you you
couldn't even imagine how you would do
that you just had to kind of assume that
that was going on and you go and measure
something else but if you if you want to
understand cause and effect and this is
something you'll be hearing some talks
about later today you
to do something more than just observe
you have to actually intervene you have
to run experiments and doing macroscale
experiments on social systems systems
that involve people is not only more
difficult it's often impossible or
unethical and so you have these you have
these tremendous constraints on what you
can do and so this makes social science
just a different kind of exercise from
physical science or biological science
where you can you can kind of set up
labs and you can study things under
controlled circumstances and so if you
think about the scientific method where
you generate your hypothesis and then
you design your experiment and you go
and measure things and then you test
your hypothesis you you sort of can't do
the second two-thirds of this much of
the time and so if you think about
what's happened over the last hundred
years social science is generated a
tremendous number of interesting
theories about the world but our ability
to test these theories and decide
between them
has been extremely limited so the
exciting thing about what's happened in
the last ten or fifteen years is that
the the technological revolution of the
web and the Internet and digital
communication and other related
technologies is starting to lift some of
these long-standing barriers and so
there's two specific ways in which this
is happening the first is the sort of
the Big Data revolution where people are
going about their ordinary business
they're communicating with each other
they're they're participating in social
media they're talking on the phone
they're sending email they're they're
collaborating and in the process they're
there they're engaging in e-commerce and
in the process they're spewing off this
enormous amount of data that is that is
you know by good fortune interesting to
social scientists so we have a this kind
of passive data collection exercise just
happening in real time and we can
benefit from all of this data to ask
interesting questions or to ask the same
questions that we've been asking all
along but we can we can
new data to bear on them and the second
thing that's happening is that we can
also use the web to to run experiments
in ways that are quite distinct from
what we've been able to do in the past
or they're analogous to that but they're
they're distinct in terms of speed and
scale so you know one thing that I'll
talk about this morning is is how we've
taken this traditional model of the lab
experiment that you're probably all
familiar with from from college you
probably either saw these things or
participated in them where there's some
sort of lab experiment happening in the
psychology department so there's a
version of that that can be done online
now and also field experiments which
perhaps soon on our I'll will talk about
today and so if you kind of lump all of
this together in a very loose sense it's
this is what we really refer to as
computational social science it's
intersection of questions that come from
the social sciences and methods that
come from the computational sciences and
so this is a very active area of
research right now and there's a lot of
excitement in this area we just ran the
second international conference on
computational social science this this
past June in Chicago and there's another
one happening in Germany next year so
this is an area that's really getting
off the ground so just to be a bit more
concrete I want to spend the rest of the
talk really just discussing two examples
of what I mean what I mean by
computational social science that
illustrate these two types of data
collections so the first one is using
passively collected data from online
sources to study this very old question
about social contagion how things spread
and the second one is using a highly
designed system where we set up a live
experiment that we have designed
ourselves and we recruit people into
paid to understand another old question
about how people solve problems in teams
and so what's you know a couple of
things that I find interesting about
this work is you know first that we're
all of it is motivated by these
long-standing questions that we have in
social science going back decades or
possibly even longer but we are also
driving using these questions to drive
kind of new methodologies that allow us
to shed new light on these questions and
then finally if I have time we can also
discuss you know what this work shows us
is problematic that you know we're able
to do lots of interesting things but in
the course of doing these things we also
realize that we have all these new
problems that we didn't that we didn't
necessarily have before and that
hopefully charts out a path for the
future of computational social science
so I'll just jump right in start talking
about the first example so when you
think about contagion
you probably have a mental model that
looks something like the following and
this is a model that underlies
essentially all of the formal
mathematical models that have been
proposed in the literature all of which
or essentially come from a notion of
biological contagion so when we the
words that we use when we talk about
things going viral or things spreading
or diffusing throughout a population
come from this biological metaphor in
which this mental model is pretty
accurate right so if you think about the
Ebola epidemic that that started in in
West Africa a couple of years ago it
really was the case that you know a
single person and index person like that
red dot and middle there was infected by
the Ebola virus we're jumping across
from some animal reservoir and then that
person went home and infected a small
number of his or her family members or
neighbors and each one
them got sick and infected a few of
their neighbors and each one of them got
sick and infected if you were their
neighbors in over the course of several
months you see thousands of people
getting infected and through this
multi-step branching process so you sort
of imagine you know at every stage is
only a few people are getting infected
by each infected person but this is
happening over and over again and you
you're getting exponential growth and so
when we talk about things going viral in
the social sphere we have the same
mental model we assume that something
like this is happening in step rather
than a disease being passed along
it's an idea or a piece of information
or a behavioral trait and in fact most
of the models that we that we use to to
describe social contagion are based on
on this assumption as well so the
problem is that when we measure things
spreading in the social world we don't
actually have data that looks like that
mental model typically what we have or
historically what we've had is data that
looks like this where you have some kind
of aggregate measure of the total number
of people who have adopted a product or
who have retweeted a tweet or have
clicked on a YouTube video and you can
measure that over time and so typically
what you get is a curve that looks like
an s-shaped curve where you see some you
know early period where a few people are
paying attention to it and then you see
this exponential growth period and then
you see some kind of asymptote where the
susceptible population gets exhausted
and and the epidemic dies out and so the
the assumption is that whenever you see
an s-shaped curve there's some contagion
process which is happening underneath
because if you simulate one of these
models you get something that looks like
that the problem empirically is that
that you can get s-shaped curves in lots
of other ways as well so just because
you're a model generates an escape shape
curve and just because you see an
s-shaped curve in the wild doesn't
mean that your your model is explaining
or causing the thing that you're looking
at and in fact there are lots of
different ways to generate their shape
codes some of which have nothing to do
with contagion at all so even if you you
could just assume that there's some kind
of heterogeneity in your population
people just have different propensity to
click on the thing or to adopt a thing
you can easily generate s-shaped curves
if you introduce any kind of marketing
or media effort you can get any shape
curve you want including an s-shaped
curve and so you really can't reject any
other model either from that sort of
evidence but there's a more subtle and
even more difficult problem with
s-shaped curves which is that you know
historically it's been data collection
has been so expensive that that social
scientists typically only study things
that succeed right so if you if you if
you look at the the history of diffusion
studies they study things that have
diffused right so you think well what
else would they study how can you study
your thing that didn't diffuse well it's
difficult but the problem is that most
things don't diffuse and if your model
is trying to explain when something
diffuses what causes successful
diffusion you have to be able to to
study the things that don't diffuse as
well so it's just like if you if you
want to understand you know what makes
certain people successful or what makes
certain companies successful you can't
just go and look at successful people
and successful companies and this may
seem surprising because if you go and
look at the business books and the
airport that's what all of them do they
go and interview successful people and
say you know what did you do and then
they kind of find some common themes and
then they make some thesis that says
well here's a hundred successful people
here's the things they told us this is
how you become successful but it turns
out that you know successful people eat
breakfast right and you know eating
breakfast is not a strong predictor of
success because unsuccessful people also
eat breakfast and it turns out this is a
one of these sort of stupid things that
you know what correlation is not
causation that everybody sort of knows
and then everybody immediately ignores
when they go on and do
they're about to do so the lesson here
is that if you want to understand what
causes diffusion you have to get all the
things that didn't diffuse as well and
so this is something that we can now do
with online data we can get individual
person-to-person level observations and
we can get them for something like a
total sample of everything that's in
some sense trying to diffuse or
everything that's at risk of diffusing
and so this is a relatively recent area
only goes back about a decade now
there's been a you know a growing list
of examples and it's a much longer list
now this is a little bit other day of
papers where people have exploited web
data to study diffusion and it allows us
to ask questions that about you know how
much when we when we see diffusion how
much of it is really viral and what do
we even mean by viral it can we be sort
of quantitative about what something a
viral thing looks like as opposed to
some other kind of spread so the first
attempt that we made to study this these
questions was a several years ago when I
was at Yahoo research with Sharad Goyal
and Dan Goldstein and we gathered
together several different projects that
we had worked on and that other people
Yahoo research had worked on that were
all originally intended to to study some
other kind of questions so we had built
a Facebook app to study how people are
similar to their friends with respect to
their political beliefs and we had
studied another we had helped the Yahoo
philanthropic team to to set up an
experiment around the holiday season to
get people to encourage their friends to
do something nice for a stranger a kind
of pay it forward style of
of social engagement our colleagues had
built this video viewing app that
allowed people to watch videos
synchronously and chat with each other
while they were doing it so these are
completely different projects they sort
of a little bit of a random selection
they varied greatly in size some of them
had hundreds of people some of them had
had tens of thousands of people involved
the only thing that they had in common
was that they all had some kind of
social referral mechanism built into
them that we wanted they were all were
some in some sense intended to spread
through a social process and other than
that the the the the variety the
heterogeneity across applications was a
as far as we were concerned a feature
and the reason is that every single one
of them was that the data collection was
very biased you know the people who are
on Facebook back then were sort of
different from other people the people
who are on Twitter back then were
different from other people the people
who were participating in the video
viewing app word were different from
other people so you have this sort of
non representative biased sample of the
population they're interacting with each
other in some sort of strange way that
might not generalize to other kinds of
cases so if you just looked at one such
example whatever result you found
someone could say well you know that
doesn't apply to anything else right
this is just sort of only restricted to
your very sort of strange example so if
you have several different strange
examples that are all biased in
different ways and you'd find the same
empirical regularity across them then
you have a much stronger claim that your
results are robust and so what we found
was actually astonishingly at least to
us astonishingly similar across these
examples so here you have six different
examples and in every example every
domain what I'm showing you here is the
five most common structures that we
observe so just to interpret this if we
look at the the top right example which
is labeled Twitter so this is a
set of 40 million tweets which sounded
like a big number back in you know a
2009 but it's uh you know you get every
day now the the first little dot there
which is telling you that ninety three
percent of the time when somebody
introduces a piece of content
represented by a URL into Twitter nobody
pays attention to it okay so this may
reflect your experience with Twitter
where you're talking and it's just sort
of going off into the ether and nobody's
paying attention to you if that if
you've had that experience you're in
you're in good company ninety-three
percent of the time that happens to
everybody
five percent of the time one of your
followers retweets your tweet right
point nine percent of the time two of
your followers retweet point three
percent of the time three of them
retweeted and point three percent of the
time you see something that starts to
look a little bit like viral spread
where one of your followers retweets it
and then one of their followers who's
not one of your followers retweets it
right so that's the interpretation of
these little motifs or structures and
what's striking is that in every case we
find almost exactly the same set of
motifs so there's the five possible
motifs for each domain there's six
domains so there's 30 possible
structures that we might see is the most
frequent structures and we only see
seven structures right so there's
tremendous consistency across these
domains and even more than that the
numbers are actually pretty similar and
so what we can do is is lump all of
these observations together and draw
this meta conclusion that about ninety
percent of the time when things are
trying to spread they don't spread all
right so most of the time nothing
happens and then most of the rest of the
time very little happens right so about
eight percent of the time you get one
subsequent adoption about one percent of
the time you get two subsequent
adoptions and then everything else
everything you've ever heard of every
viral video every
[Music]
every meme everything that you that you
that you read about everything that your
friends are talking about is in that
little blue bar on the right hand side
this 1% of the time something else
happens and so you might think well you
know that's sort of interesting but I
still don't care because I know that
these things when they happen are so big
that they really drive everything that
if you think about the you could go back
to biological disease for a moment you
know the Spanish flu which it was a
global epidemic that happened almost
exactly a century ago was a very rare
event there's been lots of instances of
influenza this was just one of them but
this one event infected a billion people
and in fact that a third of the of the
world's population you wouldn't want to
just throw that out because it's a rare
event because these rare events can be
so consequential but they're they
essentially drive everything else it
turns out that's not the case in this
data we don't have Spanish flu-like
events in fact what we can show is a
stronger statement that if you if you
look at all the adoptions everything
that happened not just the things that
that initiated cascades but all the
people in all of the Cascades 99% of
them were only one hop from the sea
right so we sort of have this intuition
that things are kind of spreading in
these large cascades but in fact almost
everything that we see looks like one of
these little motifs here and so you
might say well you know that's sort of
interesting but I actually I think
probably what you're doing is just
ignoring the most interesting stuff and
in fact that was exactly the feedback we
got when we published this paper our
colleague said you know thanks for that
but we know this stuff happens like you
know that Gangnam style was viewed by
you know a couple of billion people
around the world like I still I'm
interested in those events right I don't
care how rare they are so let's focus on
those sorts of events for a moment we
see something that is enormous Lee
a successful like a gang Gangnam style
we can still ask the question is this
thing viral or is it just popular and in
fact what do we even mean by viral like
when we when we see that something gets
you know a billion views that's really
all we know we know that it just
acquired a huge amount of views but you
know a lot of people watch the Superbowl
as well alright the Superbowl has here
maybe a hundred million viewers no one
would describe the Superbowl is a viral
phenomenon right it's just popular is a
huge broadcast event everybody goes to
the same location and they watch it on
the same news channel simultaneously and
so if we were to map a broadcast event
out in the same kind of graphical
language that we were using to look at
those motifs it would just look like a
big blob where you have when you're one
node at the center and then everybody
looks at that one node versus the the
viral model that I showed you earlier
where you have this sort of multistage
branching structure and so again when we
we see that something's popular all we
know is how many counts we have over
time we don't know what the structure is
of the underlying diffusion process and
that's what we'd like to look at and so
that led us to a second project which
again with Sharad Goyal but also with
Ashton Anderson and Jake Kaufman my
colleagues at Microsoft Research we took
a much larger data set about a billion
tweets over the course of a year
again this seemed like a big number back
in a couple of years ago but you can you
can get a billion tweets in a month now
so these what counts as big data keeps
keeps changing all the time but this was
a billion tweets over the course of 12
months more or less everything that
contained a link to a video or a news
story or an image for a petition that
was posted to Twitter for a 12-month
period so if anything is gonna go viral
we're going to see it and then the
second thing we did is we threw out
everything that you could sort of
you wasn't intended to be popular right
so one of the critiques of these one of
the tricky parts of doing this kind of
study is like clearly a lot of stuff
that people post to Twitter it's never
supposed to spread right they just you
know they're just posting it because
they're interested in or because they
want to show it to a family member or
something so you could argue that it's
sort of unfair to count everything so we
just throw out everything that isn't
plausibly popular and so in fact we we
have a very high threshold for that we
we only look at things that have at
least a hundred retweets so these things
are way more popular than anything that
I just showed you on the previous slide
so this is like one in three thousand
events qualifies as being in our data
set so we're looking at extremely rare
events but because we have over a
billion of them to start with we still
get three hundred and fifty thousand of
these rare event so this is where the
the big part of the Big Data starts to
help you is that when you're studying
rare events and you need to have a lot
of them you need to have an enormous
population to begin with okay so for
each one of these cascades which are at
least a hundred retweets in size we can
study this property that we define
called structural virality and so what
we mean by it is that if you look at one
of these if you let something diffuse so
it goes through its whole process of
cascading and at the end of it you have
some trace of where it's been right so
this is the pattern that you see and now
you have this structure you can compute
properties of it and so the property
that we're gonna compute is a fairly
simple one which is just the average
path length so how many steps does it
take to get from anyone to anyone else
in this structure which we're just going
to treat as a network or a graph
whatever we want to call it so something
that is a broadcast know where somebody
introduces something and a lot of people
retweet it and then nothing else happens
that's going to have an average path
length of close to two all right so the
the smallest structural virality you can
have is two and then if you get one of
these very large multi-step branching
processes the depth of that tree is
going to be proportional to the log of
the number of nodes in the tree and so
the average path length is also going to
be portion
to login so you for every one of these
structures you get some number that's
somewhere between two and log n and so
now you can compute that number for all
350,000 of these events and you can
start asking empirical questions about
them so you know how much diversity do
you expect to see for example so if you
look at big events do they tend to be
very viral in this structural sense lots
and lots of generations of branching
what do they tend to be very
broadcasting right and then you can also
ask well as you look at things of
different sizes do they become more
viral or more broadcasted and so you can
sort of imagine in your make a private
prediction I won't make anybody put
their hands up but you can you know
imagine like well what do you think is
like the optimal way to spread like what
kind of structure is going to generate
the the most the most spreading is it
going to be a broadcast is it going to
be a viral thing is it going to be some
kind of optimal combination of the two
and so you can come up with all kinds of
stories about what you imagine will work
better and the first answer is that
whatever story you came up with you're
right right that there's something in
there that looks like what you're
imagining there is sort of so the first
lesson here is that there is tremendous
diversity in this sort of huge
population of things that are spreading
we find almost everything right and so
if we rank so the so the first thing to
note about these pictures is they all
have the about the same number of nodes
in them so everything in here is roughly
as popular as everything else right but
the structure is wildly different so the
thing up on the top left is that that
looks like a big black triangle with
some paint dripping off it like that is
a huge broadcast node so there's a CNN
story and so CNN has lots of followers
so they post a news story and a whole
bunch of people retweet it and then
basically nothing much else happens
right all the way down on the on the
bottom right is a was a sort of
remarkable obit in the New York Times
about this this world war 2 hero
who had led this sort of incredibly
interesting life and it was not somebody
who anyone heard of and so it wasn't a
famous person but people found this very
interesting and so it got a lot of
retweets but the structure of these
retweets was totally different that you
have many many generations where just a
few people at each generation are
retweeting the previous tweet so so the
first lesson here is you have tremendous
diversity in structure the second lesson
is if you look at these little inserts
underneath the the figures that's
showing you what you would have seen
sort of in the old world where you just
got the number to count with respect to
time so this is the the non structural
data and you can see that almost all of
these things look the same there's no
way you could rank these things properly
if you just saw popularity over time the
structure is really telling us something
different about about the about the the
nature of the spreading thing and so
this is a metric which is now going into
[Music]
Bing
where we can we can use this as another
way to rank popular events and and the
hope is that that we uncover some other
feature of interestingness that is
different from just flat-out popularity
so the second question you know how do
things change with size is also somewhat
surprising but so this is now is
breaking all these events up by domain
and plotting the structural virality by
popularity so each one of these bins
contains tweets of or Cascades of
roughly the same size and the box plot
shows you the inter quartile range of
the of the structural virality and the
black bars show you the median and so
it's a couple of interesting things here
the for pictures and videos we see
almost no correlation between
structural violence eyes so big things
are no more viral and this structural
sense than small things and the reason
is that on Twitter you have you know the
these incredibly connected individuals
like the who the most popular person is
anymore I think Katy Perry overtook
Justin Bieber last year but they have
you know eighty million followers so I
mean there's sort of enormous ly
connected individuals and if one of them
gets involved then they can really
generate a huge number of retweets and
so essentially what's happening here is
that the the size the the the the size
of the entire structure is driven by the
size of the largest broadcast in that
structure and so this is what we used to
call us the Justin Bieber effect but I
guess it's now the Katy Perry effect or
whatever and it turns out that you know
celebrity so almost all the most follow
people on Twitter are celebrities and
celebrities are exclusively interested
in themselves so they don't tweet about
the news right
they just tweet pictures and videos so
if you look at pictures and videos there
it's highly celebrity driven and so you
see no correlation with news you see
more of a correlation petitions are also
interesting because they are just more
viral on average right so I think this
sort of you're sort of seeing
interesting level domain effects here
but just to sum up I think that of the
theoretical lesson here and this is
something that's you know interesting to
me in particular because I've been
involved in this theoretical literature
for you know 20 years now and there's
thousands of papers written about models
of diffusion and really they're all
concerned with this notion of the
threshold where you know that when you
get above a certain critical level of of
infectiousness you go from things dying
out to things
spreading exponentially and if you're an
epidemiologist you want to get
everything below this critical threshold
cuz you don't want things to spray
if your social marketing person you want
to get everything above the threshold
because you want your thing to go viral
but everyone is sort of worried about
this tipping point and what we find is
that this is a very misleading analogy
right that everything we see is below
this critical threshold everything is
dying out all the time and the only
thing that is driving it are these big
hubs these these large seeds so we have
to sort of think differently about how
things spread in a social environment
then how they spread in a biological
environment and so we need to kind of
break this historical analogy that we've
been relying on for our models and of
course you know once you understand that
then is that you can you can also think
differently about how you're going to to
apply this in practice and finally I
think you know again in in in in my
world there's sort of a lot of criticism
of Big Data because it has all kinds of
problems that I'm sure you you know
about but this is really an example
where the size of the data set is really
helpful but if you're looking for rare
events and and you know it's number of
places in in social science where we do
in fact care about rare events it's very
difficult to study rare events and this
is so having a large data set like this
really enables you to do things that
historically you could not do okay so
okay so I want to talk about the second
problem now which is using a different
type of data generating mechanism a lab
environment to study problem solving how
many few minutes oh okay all right let
me just try to sum up so we're
interested in how groups of people solve
problems
just trust me people have been thinking
about this for a long time we have no
idea we would like to do this in an
experimental setting and so as I
mentioned earlier you know we can now
take this historical model of the lab
which you see on the you know in the
sort of grainy black-and-white picture
here and we can do it online using sites
like Amazon's Mechanical Turk and so the
problem that that we studied is a
problem that you may have heard of
it's called crisis mapping this is a
real thing that people do in the world
when there's a crisis happening
somewhere like a natural disaster like
in Haiti the earthquake in 2010
volunteers assemble online and they what
they do is they monitor all the social
media activity of users on the ground
and they classify all this noisy
unstructured data to find where things
are damaged where people are needing
help and they can then hand this cleaned
up structured data set in the form of a
map and crisis map to an agency like the
UN which is then uses the map to direct
resources so this is a useful thing it's
a complex task
it's a real-world task and what we're
interested in is is using this task as a
way to understand how people collaborate
in a controlled environment and so this
is a virtual lab experiment using
software that was developed by one of
our postdocs Andrew mal so this runs on
meteor and uses some software that he
wrote called tooks over
which recruits people from Amazon
Mechanical Turk and then brings them
into this experimental setting and what
they're doing here is they're we give
them about 1,500 tweets which are real
tweets from Twitter users in the
Philippines in December 2012 when the
Philippines was hit by a typhoon typhoon
Pablo and so you can see what what
happened is this typhoon swept through
the center of the Philippines there and
people are tweeting about it and most of
these tweets are not very informative
but some of them contain very concrete
information about damage on the ground
and so the objective is that these group
of stalkers have to find the relevant
tweets extract the relevant information
from those tweets classify these events
in terms of is it damaged housing is it
displaced population are the deaths
reported what is the description and
then they have to geo locate them on
this map and this is difficult because
these are not geo tagged tweets you have
to sort of do some sleuthing to figure
out like where this is and then they are
putting it there then creating this map
and they're doing all this in the course
of an hour right so this is a you know
this sort of complex ambiguous exercise
they're not given a lot of training in
it in advance and so they're also trying
to figure out how to do it so there's a
lot of chatting going on here so we're
really sort of studying this very rich
team collaborative exercise with a with
a with a relatively claimed performance
outcome which is how good a job did I do
of creating this map and globally they
do pretty well right so this is the
actual map which was produced by you
know 32 volunteers over 12 hours in 2012
and this is the map that our experiment
subjects produced in one hour a couple
of years later and they're actually
quite similar the difference is that we
are able to measure everything so we can
we can see you know every action that
everyone takes everything that everybody
says to somebody else and so we can look
at communication we can look at division
of labor and we can look at performance
and we can do this
for a large number of groups of
different sizes and we
can for each one of them the maps we can
we can construct a fairly clean measure
of quality how well they are able to to
identify the events that matter and so
the sort of short version is that if you
if you look at how the performance
varies with the size of the team it's
true that teams larger teams do better
than smaller teams so that seems
reasonable but it's also clear that
there's this sort of strong diminishing
returns to scale right that larger teams
are not doing proportionally better than
individuals and so maybe you think well
you know and so you can ask why that is
and the the answer is that people tend
to slack off when they're around other
people so this is a phenomenon called
that psychologists call social loafing
economists call it free writing so all
this sounds very plausible but then
something else turns up which is that in
larger teams there's a this other
benefit that you get from being in a
team which is that you know people are
kind of are checking each other's work
people are realizing that they're both
working on the same problem and
eliminating redundancies and so even
though there's a sort of tension here
where you find that you know when there
are other people around you're less
likely to work as hard but when there
are other people around you get some
sort of benefit as well and so you want
to try to to balance up these two
competing forces well it's unclear which
one is is more salient and so we have a
way of doing that by creating synthetic
groups out of individual workers so we
have all these people who are doing this
on their own and we can combine their
maps to create you know what they would
have done if we had treated them as a
team and so we find this very kind of
interesting and I think non obvious
result which is that if we compare the
synthetic teams to the real teams the
blue line is the synthetic teams the
real the green
as the real teams that first up to a
certain critical size the synthetic
teams are doing better so the the sort
of per capita effort is winning for a
while but then as the team size
increases the the the error checking and
and deduping that happens in the real
teams starts to win out and so the
largest team levels largest team sizes
you find that the teams are actually
better than individuals and
interestingly the red line shows you the
performance of the actual stand by task
force so as a sort of measure of
external validity we're running an
experiment here that is almost exactly I
mean it's not exactly like real-life but
it's very close to real life and so this
is you know something that is
tremendously exciting to us because you
know again if you go back through the
history of lab experiments they tend to
be extremely artificial and so you can
conduct these sort of nice clean
experiments but then you have to kind of
wave your hand about how the result
plays out in real life where lots of
other things are going on as well and
it's much Messier and so if we want to
understand how real teams and real
organizations perform and what is draw
you know which which factors drive
performance we have to be able to to to
strike a balance between lab light
control and and and naturalism and so
this is sort of getting much closer to
that so I think we are out of time but I
just want to say that you know sort of
end on a note of caution that that you
know this has been an extremely exciting
past decade there are things that we can
do now that were were quite unimaginable
to us just a decade ago in terms of the
the questions that we can answer the the
data that we can collect so there's
really enormous excitement there's new
conferences there's new research centres
there's new journals that new funding
agencies so there's a lot of interest in
computational approaches to social
science but there are some very large
challenges like in some sense you know
we are not any closer than we were a 10
or 15 years ago to answering the big
questions of social science that kind of
got all of us into this profession to
begin with and so going forward I think
we have to ask ourselves some some
serious questions about how we're going
to get the data that is the right data
so it's great to study retweets on
Twitter but in some sense you know we
don't really care about Twitter we care
about you know how does health behavior
spread through you know through the
population you know how do how do you
know cultural beliefs change like these
are the things that matter to the world
and these are the things that matter to
social science and you can kind of
squint your eyes and imagine that that
what we're studying on Twitter is sort
of like there's other stuff that we
really care about but at the end of the
day we have to really study the thing
that we care about and that's going to
require some some some serious
conversations between us and also
between US and industry in terms of you
know what we can measure how we can
build the instruments that are most
relevant to us and and and how we can
take what is sort of intriguing and
thought-provoking and and and turn it
into something that is that is
consequential for business and also for
society so on that note thanks very much
[Applause]